merci c'est pas seulement le juriste qui
parle c'est aussi l'élu local le premier
adjoint de melun le président la
communauté d'agglomération melun qui a
défrayé la chronique il ya peu de temps
et qui sait comment les problèmes de
sécurité peuvent se poser dans une ville
de cette taille 1 40 mille habitants
alors je crois que pour nos concitoyens
il y a deux choses deux chiffres qui
sont devenues inacceptables
inacceptables ils ont été cités
plusieurs fois plusieurs reprises ce
matin cent mille peines non exécutées
c'est inacceptable la loi doit être
appliquée
il vaut mieux pas de loi qu'une loi
inappliquée tous les comportements
déviants ce sont des comportements qui
se constatent parce que justement on
sait qu'on n'effectuera pas sa peine le
2e chiffre c'est les deux ans on peut
être condamné à deux ans de prison ferme
sans mettre les pieds en prison
ça aussi c'est tout à fait inacceptable
deux ans c'est grave
deux ans c'est grave ce sont des
délinquants graves et puis deux ans ça
veut dire des récidivistes et on sait
les problèmes que ça pose alors la
question qu'on se pose c'est comment en
sommes-nous arrivés là
comment est ce que c'est possible qu'un
pays comme la france en soit arrivé là
première raison il faut la chercher à
gauche il ya un discours idéologique
complètement irresponsable qui ruinent
l'autorité de l'état et il faut lutter
contre ce discours
deuxième raison il ya aussi des torts de
notre côté d'abord nous avons été
empêchés de réaliser notre programme
nous avions lancé un programme de ppp
il a été interrompu donc on s'est
arrêtés en route
deuxième chose les deux ans c'est une
réforme mal pensé et c'est une très
bonne idée enfin que nous voulions
aujourd'hui repartir sur six mois bien
sûr bien sûr c'est ce qu'il faut faire
quel est le résultat de tout ça le
résultat c'est finalement une
démoralisation de nos forces de sécurité
ils démoralisation de nos magistrats
en fait la chaîne pénale elle est unique
il y a deux jambes il faut si vous nous
voulons assurer la sécurité de
constituer un marcher sur les deux
jambes il y à la police et il ya la
justice
je pense donc il faut absolument que
nous reprenions tout
tout ce chantier et il est important de
faire avancer les deux du même pas
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire 3-3 piste
première chose il faut évidemment
augmenter le nombre de places de prison
plus de 20000 c'est la fourchette basse
plus trente mille c'est la fourchette
haute
il faut évidemment en passer par là il
faut relancer des ppp
il faut optimiser l'investissement dans
les prisons 6 cd mesure de semi liberté
c'est pas la peine de mettre des
miradors
il faut accroître le financement le
financement c'est la deuxième piste
il faut absolument nous avons augmenté
le financement en ce qui concerne la
justice mais ce n'est pas suffisant si
nous voulons nous doter d'une justice
dignes d'une grande démocratie moderne
il suffit de se comparer avec les autres
pays il faut nécessairement augmenter le
financement la justice comment faire
comment faire peut-être une idée pour le
professeur d'université que que je suis
toujours ce qu'on a fait pour les
universités pourquoi est ce qu'on ne
ferait pas pour la justice
si on a privatisé une partie du capital
d'une grande entreprise publique
et si on a pris cet argent pour remettre
des universités à flot pourquoi est ce
que la justice ne mérite-t-elle pas les
sommes sont moins importantes
il faut absolument que nous décidions
d'agir pour notre justice
et c'est pas seulement une question
matérielle c'est une question morale il
ya mille postes vacants dans la
pénitence et à plus de 1000 postes
vacants dans un paysage pénitentiaire il
ya plus de 1000 postes de magistrats
vacants
ça veut dire quelque chose dernier axe
il faut rétablir la confiance la
confiance entre notre police et notre
justice il faut reconstruire la chaîne
pénale il faut rétablir la cohérence
en ce moment on sent on se relance la
balle c'est pas du tout c'est pas du
tout la bonne direction pour rétablir la
confiance
il faut absolument que le ministère de
la justice se recentre sur les tâches
essentielles d'où cette idée peut être
de se décharger d'un tas d'une certaine
nom de tâches accessoires mais dont le
champ de sa compétence
il faut que le ministre d'alger le
ministère de la justice on regagne toute
son autorité
comment peut-on imaginer qu'une loi
comme la loi macron qui vient d'être
adoptée qui concerne toutes les
professions juridiques judiciaires
les officiers d'étaler des officiers
ministériels les auxiliaires de justice
et une grande un grand pan de notre
droit des affaires
comment peut-on imaginer qu'une loi
pareille soit adoptée sans que le
ministre a juste ici participe de façon
très active
donc ce qu'il faut en définitive ce que
je propose c'est on l'a évoqué ce matin
un plan marshall pour la justice c'est
tout ce dont nous avons besoin